today we're gonna talk about my my hot
dad there is an email that went around
looking for a tract of dead I knew my
dad was attractive a couple people were
applied and then I dropped the bomb and
literally in the caption of the email
said I couldn't bring him on field trips
because all my classmates were just
elevating over the man and what happens
right when I send that email a laundry
list of multiple people in this office
you can't contain themselves bringing my
dad around ruined a lot of potential
relationships growing up he's very
charismatic and he had good style so I
can't deal with him in suits so I
wouldn't be hiding on the other side of
this wall I'm just supposed to hear
their reactions from my co-workers yes
he looked through a gallery of photos of
my father's a little nervous I mean
honestly I was like if he about this
whole experience so we basically heard
that Eli's dad is a baddie and we wanted
to you know find out for herself mm-hmm
I want to look at him I think single for
a while I'm not ashamed to say that
thirsty but I am gonna be ashamed
what is it led to before discussing
Eli's dad and I don't know how I feel
about it
new years ago his dad came to visit him
in LA he has a friend oh you know I'd
love to meet your dad he's like no stay
away you thirsty
and I was like okay so I'm curious to
see why he was already trying to thwart
me off with his dad let's take a look
yep bring me those pics are there dick
pics it's a very funny style yeah he
looks like he chills at a bar he looks a
lot like you guys he's like got the
slightly open mouth feel like he knows
how he is oh yeah
yes
I always thought up to we're too tall Oh
someone daddy like as in sexual it's
kind of weird
he is someone's daddy I now know why he
was telling me to stay away is it we
need to bring your father to work day
[Music]
how come you I don't be dressing like
that oh you know what they say I don't
know I'm friends with you I meant I
would not date his dad it's really off
of respect for my good friend Eli first
now you are my wife so all this is
disgusting okay Matt secondly this is
the dirtiest things I've ever heard come
out a sweet sweet Matt's mouth okay give
me a hug
that was so sweet I was honestly
expecting the worst
I was worried about Chris what shook me
the most was the very beginning where
you said you don't know what you would
do out of the outcome of this so I'm
like is he gonna masturbate to my dad I
was like I was just like I really didn't
want that was like oh he's from Texas oh
my god [ __ ] I know I already know
someone's gonna [ __ ] say the joke
don't say it I know my if there he goes
yeah I love how you're avoiding
everything like Oh what is this business
behind there oh he's drinking a beer
just know that I chose you
okay so I knew this would suck I was
surprised when I thought certain people
would be chill about it they weren't and
when I thought people would just be
nasty they were really sweet about it
okay got nice complexion he's an
attractive man kate was honestly the
sweetest person ever your dad buddy
that's great
every I'm like you know my great friend
Eli I wouldn't do so and there's a puppy
oh my god friendship and puppies you
don't get any sweeter than that someone
that respectful while holding a puppy
that's like the best combo ever I feel
good because he has great genes he's a
loving father sweet guy I'm lucky enough
to have a young dad that I could spend a
lot of memories with hopefully I look
nearly as good as him when I'm his age
so I found out there was a messaging
thread going around at the office and it
was about my dad I'm seeing this for the
first time everyone's freaking up okay
where's the research team they're trying
to find the research team to figure out
where's my dad